ALL RIGHT. WE WILL BEGIN THE
COMMITTEE ON BANKING AND
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS. TODAY.
WE HAVE ONE BILL THAT IS UP.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE, AND THEN WE WILL
ASK FOR A ROLL CALL WHEN WE HAVE
QUORUM. SO WE WILL BEGIN WITH
SENATE BILL 378. SENATOR DODD,
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, I'M PRESENTING SB 278
PERTAINING TO ELDER FINANCIAL
ABUSE. SB 278 IS ABOUT
PROTECTING SENIORS FROM
FINANCIAL SCAMS. AS AMENDED, SB
278 WOULD ENACT THE CALIFORNIA
EMERGENCY FINANCIAL CONTACT
PROGRAM FOR FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS WHO ARE MANDATED
REPORTERS OF SUSPECTED ELDER
ABUSE IN CALIFORNIA AND WOULD
OUTLINE WHAT IS EXPECTED OF THEM
IF THEY REASONABLY SUSPECT ABUSE
IS OCCURRING. THE BILL WAS
AMENDED IN THE ASSEMBLY TO
REQUIRE FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
TO NOTIFY A JOINT ACCOUNT HOLDER
OR EMERGENCY FINANCIAL CONTACT
OF SUSPECTED ABUSE OF A SENIOR
IF A TRUSTED CONTACT HAS BEEN
PROVIDED, AND TO DELAY BY THREE
BUSINESS DAYS. THE TRANSACTION,
IF THEY REASONABLY SUSPECT
ABUSE. AMENDMENTS PROVIDE BANKS
AND CREDIT UNIONS WITH LIABILITY
PROTECTIONS WHEN THEY PROPERLY
CARRY OUT THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES, AS SET FORTH
IN THE STATUTE. AMENDMENTS DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION BY ONE YEAR TO
GIVE FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS TIME
TO IMPLEMENT THE LAW AND
AMENDMENTS INCLUDE ENFORCEMENT
PROVISIONS FOR ANY INSTITUTION
THAT REPEATEDLY VIOLATES A LAW
OR VIOLATES THE LAW WITH
RECKLESS DISREGARD. FINALLY, AND
IMPORTANTLY, THE AMENDMENTS
CLEARLY PROVIDE THAT IF THE
APPLICATION OF THE ENFORCEMENT
PROVISIONS ARE HELD INVALID FOR
ONE COVERED ENTITY, THE
ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS ARE
INVALID FOR ALL. THE BILL ENJOYS
BROAD SUPPORT FROM CONSUMER AND
LEGAL AID ORGANIZATIONS, SENIOR
AND DISABILITY RIGHTS GROUPS,
AND MANY MORE. THERE IS NO
LONGER ANY OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL. I'M GOING TO REPEAT THAT
THERE'S NO LONGER ANY OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL BECAUSE WE HAD A
GREAT BANKING CHAIRPERSON HERE
IN THE SENATE AND ALSO IN THE
ASSEMBLY, AND WE WORKED WITH
THE, YOU KNOW, THE PROPONENTS
AND THE OPPOSITION TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DIALED THIS BILL IN JUST
RIGHT. MEMBERS. THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL TO PROTECT A
VULNERABLE AND GROWING
POPULATION OF SENIOR CITIZENS. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
SENATOR DODD. WE DO HAVE QUORUM,
SO WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
CALL THE ROLL, PLEASE. SENATOR
LEHMAN. HERE. LEHMAN. HERE.
MILO. MILO. HERE. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. HERE. CABALLERO MEN.
HERE. MEN. HERE NGUYEN. NGUYEN.
HERE. PORTANTINO WE HAVE FIVE.
ALL RIGHT, SO WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED QUORUM. THANK YOU,
SENATOR DODD, DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? PLEASE,
JUST TWO MINUTES. GOOD
AFTERNOON. JUST VERY BRIEFLY,
DANNY KAISER, ON BEHALF OF THE
CO-SPONSORS OF THE BILL, THE
CALIFORNIA LOW INCOME CONSUMER
COALITION, AS WELL AS ELDER LAW
AND ADVOCACY, ALSO STATING
SPONSORSHIP OF THE OTHER
CO-SPONSOR, CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. GREAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
PLEASE JUST STATE YOUR NAME AND
POSITION. SEEING NO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION MEMBERS. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? WE'RE
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
MEMBERS. THE BILL. ALL RIGHT.
AND VICE CHAIR NEAL. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR, SENATOR DODD, I
COMPLIMENT YOU FOR TACKLING WHAT
IS KIND OF A IT'S OBVIOUSLY A
PROBLEM, AND IT'S DIFFICULT TO
ADDRESS. AND I THINK THE
DIFFICULTY IS REFLECTED IN HOW
THE BILL IS CHANGED FROM ITS
ORIGINAL FORM TO NOW. FIRST OF
ALL, A QUESTION. THERE IS A
COVERED ACCOUNT HOLDER AND IT
MEANS AN ACCOUNT HOLDER WHO IS
AN ELDER OR DEPENDENT ADULT. HOW
DO WE DEFINE THAT? HOW DOES A
BANK DEFINE THAT? IS IT OF A
CERTAIN AGE? AND DO THEY HAVE TO
BE FORMALLY NOTIFIED THAT AN
ADULT IS A DEPENDENT ADULT? HI,
JACKIE. ON BEHALF OF CONSUMER
ATTORNEYS, ONE OF THE
CO-SPONSORS. CAN YOU REPEAT THAT
QUESTION? I'M SORRY. HOW DOES A
BANK KNOW THAT A ACCOUNT HOLDER
IS AN ELDER OR A DEPENDENT
ADULT? YEAH. SO THE BANK HAS THE
INFORMATION OF THE PERSON'S
BIRTHDAY. SO THEY WOULD BE ABLE
TO KNOW IF THEY'RE OVER 65. AND
THE BILL INCLUDES LANGUAGE FOR
DEPENDENT ADULT. THEY HAVE TO
HAVE ACTUAL KNOWLEDGE. SO THAT'S
THE STANDARD FOR DEPENDENT
ADULTS. SO THEY MAY NOT KNOW
THAT IT'S A DEPENDENT ADULT FOR
DEPENDENT ADULTS. THAT'S
CORRECT. THEY WOULD HAVE TO HAVE
ACTUAL KNOWLEDGE SO THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE TO BE TOLD OR SOME
OTHER WAY THAT THEY HAVE THAT
KNOWLEDGE. THE BILL DOESN'T SAY
AGE 65, THOUGH, AT LEAST NOT
THAT I CAN SEE. SO THE BILL
REFERS TO THE MANDATED REPORTING
STATUTE. SO THAT'S THE CURRENT
LAW. IS THAT FOR MANDATED
REPORTERS OF SUSPECTED ABUSE,
THE STANDARD IS 65 AND OLDER. SO
THAT IS WHAT WE'RE REFERENCING.
SORRY I RAN OVER HERE, SO I
APOLOGIZE. I UNDERSTAND. OKAY.
IN OTHER WORDS, ARE YOU RELYING
ON THE AUTHORITY ELSEWHERE IN
CODE FOR THAT DEFINITION? THAT'S
CORRECT. OKAY NOW, THE CONCERN
THAT I HAVE, YOU KNOW, IF YOU
DEPOSIT A CHECK FROM BANK OF
AMERICA TO WELLS FARGO, YOU
CAN'T USE THOSE FUNDS FOR A FEW
DAYS BECAUSE OF THE FLOAT,
RIGHT? I'M SURE YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH THAT PRACTICE. IT'S FAIRLY
STANDARD. THE MONEY IS AVAILABLE
TO YOU AFTER A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
DAYS. MY CONCERN IS THAT'S
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN WITH
REGARD TO THIS. ANYBODY OVER 65,
IF THEY WANT TO WITHDRAW $5,000,
THE BANK'S GOING TO DELAY IT FOR
THREE DAYS BECAUSE THE, THE
REASONABLE SUSPICION IS GOING TO
BE PROVEN BY WHETHER THERE'S
ABUSE OR NOT. AND IF THERE IS NO
REASONABLE SUSPICION, BUT THE
BANK IS LOOKING AT A POTENTIAL
VIOLATION, I REALIZE IF IT'S
REPEATED. BUT THE POINT IS, THE
BANK IS LOOKING AT A POTENTIAL
VIOLATION IF THERE ENDS UP BEING,
ABUSE OF ANY SORT, THEN THE
SEEMS TO ME THE NATURAL BEHAVIOR
OF THE BANK IS TO HANDLE THAT,
JUST LIKE THEY DO A DEPOSIT OF A
CHECK FROM ANOTHER BANK AND JUST
EXPLAIN TO THE ELDER, I'M SORRY,
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
PROCESS THIS TRANSACTION FOR
THREE DAYS. WHAT'S TO, PUSH BACK
ON MY CONTENTION? WELL, LET ME
START AND THEN BACK ME UP HERE.
FIRST OF ALL, MOST OF THESE THAT
HAVE BEEN A PROBLEM HAVE BEEN IN
WIRE WIRE TRANSFERS, NOT BANK TO
BANK TRANSFERS, NOT NECESSARILY,
YOU KNOW, A CHECK HERE OR A
CHECK THERE. I WOULD SAY,
BECAUSE THIS HAS BEEN BROUGHT UP
BY BY THE BANKS TO ME, SENATOR,
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF
YOUR COLLEAGUES ARE GOING TO BE
UPSET ABOUT THIS BECAUSE BANKS
ARE GOING TO START WITHHOLDING
THESE TRANSACTIONS FOR YOU KNOW,
FOR THREE DAYS. I WOULD SUGGEST
TO YOU THAT IF A CUSTOMER IS IN
FRONT OF THE IN FRONT OF THEIR
BANKER TRYING TO WIRE $25,000,
LET'S JUST SAY, FOR EXAMPLE,
SOME WERE FOR AN INVESTMENT
SOMEWHERE FOR A CHILD OR
ANYTHING ELSE. AND THEY CAN'T
EXPLAIN TO THE BANK OR
SATISFACTION THAT THIS IS A
LEGITIMATE TRANSACTION, THAT
THEY KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE
DOING, THAT THEY PROBABLY OUGHT
TO HOLD IT FOR, FOR THEY
PROBABLY OUGHT TO HOLD IT FOR,
FOR THREE DAYS. AND I JUST THINK
THIS IDEA THAT THE BANK IS GOING
TO ARBITRARILY HOLD EVERYTHING
FOR THREE DAYS IS NOT
WELL-FOUNDED, BECAUSE THE, THE,
THE BANK, FIRST OF ALL, THEY'VE
TAKEN THE STEPS. THEY'VE ASKED
THEM THE APPROPRIATE QUESTIONS,
THEY'VE COMPLIED WITH THE LAW.
SOONER OR LATER, THIS CUSTOMER
IS GOING TO GO TO A DIFFERENT
BANK, ONE THAT MAYBE, PERHAPS
KNOWS THEIR CUSTOMER BETTER.
THAT'S WHAT I'VE GOT TO SAY TO
THIS, AND I WOULD JUST ADD THAT
I THINK WITH ANY POLICY CHANGE,
THERE'S ALWAYS A POSSIBILITY
THAT THERE IS MORE OF A
BALANCING FACTOR ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER. MAYBE ONE BANK WILL BE
MORE CAUTIOUS, DEPENDING ON, YOU
KNOW, THERE MIGHT BE LIKE A
PERTINENT TYPE OF SCAM GOING
AROUND AND IT FLAGS THINGS FOR
THEM. THEY MAY DELAY THINGS IF
THOSE THINGS ARE FLAGGED. I
THINK IT'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE A
BALANCING. AND IN OUR VIEW, WE
WERE TRYING TO BE VERY CAREFUL
AND TRY TO GIVE THE BANKS THE
WHAT THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THE BEST DECISION GIVEN,
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE THE ONES
INTERACTING WITH THE CONSUMER.
THEY KNOW THEIR CONSUMERS,
ESPECIALLY THE SMALLER BANKS,
COMMUNITY BANKS. SO I THINK
GIVING THEM THAT TOOL THAT THEY
NEED TO IF THEY REALLY DO
REASONABLY SUSPECT THAT THERE'S
FRAUD, GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
TO, YOU KNOW, CALL THE TRUSTED
CONTACT OR A JOINT ACCOUNT
HOLDER, USUALLY AN OLDER, YOU
KNOW, A KID THAT'S ON THE
ACCOUNT, LIKE I'M ON MY PARENTS
ACCOUNT. SO I THINK WE WERE
TRYING TO GIVE THEM THAT
OPPORTUNITY. I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT. THERE MAY ALWAYS BE THAT
POSSIBILITY OF AN INCONVENIENCE.
RIGHT BUT I THINK ON BALANCE, IF
IT'S GOING TO RESULT IN SENIORS
NOT LOSING THEIR LIFE SAVINGS, I
THINK IT'S A WORTHWHILE
ANALYSIS. SO I DON'T WANT TO
DRAW THIS OUT. BUT YOU SAY THE
BANKER IS REVIEWING THIS IN
THIS. IN MOST CASES, THE BANKER
IS A 25 YEAR OLD TELLER WHO'S
STANDING ON THE OTHER SIDE OF A
TELLER WITH A BUNCH OF MORE
PEOPLE IN LINE, TRYING TO PURSUE
TRANSACTIONS. AND SO THE BANK'S
GOING TO HAVE TO SET UP SOME
PROCEDURE. OKAY. THE CUSTOMER
WALKS IN, THE CUSTOMER IS OVER
65. FLAG FOR THE TELLER. SEND
THEM TO A MANAGER TO TALK ABOUT
IT. I GUESS. BUT PERHAPS ARE
THERE ANY BANKERS IN THE ROOM
THAT COULD, PROVIDE SOME WISDOM
TO ME ON WHAT MY CONCERN IS? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE, I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO. OKAY WELL, MY
ONLY POINT IS THE YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT ON BALANCE. ON BALANCE, A
BANKER DOES NOT WANT TO BE
ACCUSED OF VIOLATING THIS LAW.
NOT ONLY IS THERE ARE THERE
CONSEQUENCES, BUT IT WOULD BE
EXTREMELY POOR PUBLICITY.
PUBLICITY. AND THE ONLY WAY TO
AVOID THAT IS TO JUST DELAY FOR
THREE DAYS. ANY TRANSACTION THAT
COMES BEFORE A TELLER BY
SOMEBODY WHO'S OVER 65. I
REALIZE YOU DISAGREE WITH ME.
I'M JUST EXPRESSING. THAT'S MY
CONCERN. SENATOR I EVEN WENT TO,
MY BANK, WHICH IS MECHANICS
BANK, AND I WENT TO A DIFFERENT,
BECAUSE I NEEDED TO GET AN
INVESTMENT IN. I WENT TO A BANK
RIGHT UP HERE. ACTUALLY, IT WAS
UP THE ROAD IN ROCKLAND TO DO A
TRANSACTION TO BE ABLE TO WIRE
IT UP. THEY NEEDED ORIGINAL
SIGNATURE. I WENT TO THIS BANK
AND THEY HAD A LIST TO TELL HER
RIGHT THERE. HAD A LIST OF
QUESTIONS. DO YOU KNOW WHO THIS
PERSON IS? THAT YOU'RE WIRING
THIS MONEY TO, YOU KNOW, AND
THEY ASKED THE QUESTIONS, AND I
WAS JUST ABSOLUTELY BLOWN AWAY.
THE ISSUE IS THERE ARE A LOT OF
GREAT BANKS THAT PROBABLY
REPRESENTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
BANKERS ASSOCIATION OR THE
CREDIT UNIONS THAT ARE ALREADY
DOING THIS, AND THEY'RE DOING IT
VERY SUCCESSFULLY.
UNFORTUNATELY, WE DO NOT HAVE
BILLS FOR THOSE THAT ARE GOOD
ACTORS. WE'RE TRYING TO TAKE
CARE OF THE BAD ACTORS AND
MAKING SURE THAT THEY DO THE
WORK, JUST LIKE THE GOOD BANKS
THAT ARE DOING THAT KIND OF WORK
EVERY SINGLE DAY. I REALLY
BELIEVE THAT WE FINE TUNE THIS.
WE'VE WORKED WITH THE BANKS,
WE'VE WORKED WITH THE CREDIT
UNIONS TO THE POINT WHERE THEIR
OPPOSITION IS NO LONGER HERE.
AND I WOULD SUGGEST THAT IF THE
BANKS ARE HAVE CHANGED THEIR
POSITION ON THIS, THAT PERHAPS
YOU TWO CAN. SENATOR THANK YOU.
FIRST OF ALL, I THINK I THANK
YOU FOR DOING BUSINESS IN MY
DISTRICT, ROCKLAND. BUT
SECONDLY, I TRANSACT WITH BANKS
ALSO, AND I'M A LITTLE BIT OLDER
THAN YOU. MAYBE I LOOK A LOT
YOUNGER, BUT I'M OLDER THAN YOU
AND I'VE NOT EXPERIENCED THAT,
SO I THINK IT'S SOMEWHAT
INCONSISTENT. THANK YOU MEMBERS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
WE DO HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
MAIN. I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND SPONSORS AND EVERYBODY FOR
ALL YOUR WORK. THIS HAS BEEN A
TWO YEAR PROCESS OF THIS
DISCUSSION FOR THIS BILL. I WILL
ALSO SAY THAT I THINK THAT THIS
ADDS AN ADDITIONAL TOOL FOR
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS FOR OUR
BANKS. I THINK OF THE FACT THAT
MY PARENTS HAVE THEIR FAVORITE
TELLER THAT THEY GO TO, AND
THEY'VE BEEN GOING TO TALK TO
THAT TELLER FOR OVER 20 YEARS,
AT THEIR LOCAL CREDIT UNION. AND
I KNOW I AM VERY CONFIDENT THAT
IF THAT TELLER SAW SOMETHING
THAT WAS INCONSISTENT OR
SUSPICIOUS BECAUSE OF THAT 20
YEAR RELATIONSHIP, THEY WOULD
FLAG IT IN A WAY. AND I THINK
THAT THIS PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL
TOOL. I'M PARTICULARLY THANKFUL
FOR THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE
TAKEN TO THINK ABOUT OUR
COMMUNITY. BANKS AND SOME OF OUR
MORE LOCAL BANKS THAT DO HAVE
THAT PERSONAL INTERACTION AND
THAT THEY KNOW THE PATTERNS,
TRENDS OF THEIR, YOU KNOW, OF
THEIR CUSTOMERS IN A MORE
INTIMATE WAY. AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE ALSO IN A
PLACE THAT THIS WORKS FOR THEM.
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS AND ALLOW YOU
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR. I REALLY WOULD LIKE
TO THANK OUR SPONSORS, BUT
MOREOVER, NOT MOREOVER, THE SAME
AMOUNT OF THANKS TO, YOU KNOW,
TO THE, THE BANKERS, THE CBA, TO
THE CREDIT UNION REPRESENTATIVES
AND ALSO THE COMMUNITY BANKS FOR
COMING TO THE TABLE, CONTINUING
TO COME TO THE TABLE AND WORKING
THESE ISSUES OUT TO WHERE WE I
THINK WE HAVE AN ACCEPTABLE BILL
THAT'S GOING TO PROTECT SENIORS
FROM HERE ON IN. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. GREAT.
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
SENATOR MAIN. THE MOTION IS FOR
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS BE
CONCURRED IN, CAN WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL? SENATE BILL 279. THE
MOTION IS THAT THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
SENATOR LEÓN. AYE. LIMÓN. AYE
NHIÀU. BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
MEN. ALL RIGHT. MEN I NGUYEN
PORTANTINO. PORTANTINO. AYE
THANK YOU SO THIS BILL HAS FIVE
VOTES WE WILL WAIT FOR I THINK,
ONE ABSENT MEMBER. IF THAT
MEMBER CAN COME HERE. OTHERWISE
WE WILL HAVE TO CLOSE THE ROLL.
GIVEN THAT THERE IS ANOTHER
COMMITTEE THAT IS WAITING FOR
THE HEARING ROOM. SO WITH THAT,
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
CLOSE THE ROLL AND ADJOURN OUR
COMMITTEE ON BANKING AND
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS. WAIT
WAIT WAIT.